uno de los principales compradores de
soya este no esté bien que usted
destacaba que es una la principal la
producción agrícola de Paraguay uno de
los principales compradores es china no
con quién Paraguay mantiene relaciones
comerciales sin embargo no relaciones
diplomáticas porque como decíamos
Paraguay es uno de los 13 países a nivel
mundial que reconoce a Taiwán como
estado soberano entonces este elemento
ha sido discutido durante la campaña
Efraín alegre decía que revisaría estas
relaciones mientras que Santiago Peña
dice que va a continuar con la misma
posición a tradicional de reconocimiento
hacia Taiwán por qué estas posiciones
digamos tan marcadas por parte del
partido Colorado que distan de algunos
otros países de la región que en los
últimos en los últimos meses Incluso
como es el caso de Honduras han decidido
que por necesidad económica incluso les
convenía
digamos reconocer y establecer lazos
diplomáticos con china Cuál es la
particularidad de Paraguay en este caso
Bueno ahí Creo que volviendo a lo que
había comentado anteriormente esta idea
del pragmatismo creo que se va a
mantener digamos no no de hecho ya en
campaña desde desde
Santiago Peña digamos no surgió esta
esta propuesta o esta posibilidad o esta
idea de este de virar estas relaciones
hacia china más bien la planteaba Efraín
alegre yo creo que lo que va a primar de
vuelta es el pragmatismo es esta
relación que el partido Colorado ya
históricamente ha decidido mantener
con con Taiwán que además genera una
serie indudablemente de este
cooperaciones y de beneficios
quizás en muchos casos de
Santiago no sé si si estamos
Hola perdiendo esta conexión parece que
que la hemos podido restablecer
hola hola sí sí continúe
Ok decía que
más bien es una relación
pragmática y que beneficia sobre todo
los intereses muchas veces de este
dirigentes políticos individuales que se
benefician también de estas
contraprestaciones Así que creo que eso
no va a variar y y lo que va a primar es
el pragmatismo de de Peña en ese sentido
en esta relación con con Taiwán el
aspecto del del cambio climático
mencionado es un uno de los grandes
desafíos
que va a tener este este gobierno electo
y que va a obligar al a Santiago Peña a
establecer acuerdos amplios con sectores
de oposición e incluso
unificar internamente a su partido
porque internamente tiene también
detractores muy importantes Pero estos
grandes desafíos el cambio climático la
educación
el acceso a salud de calidad
todos indicadores donde el Paraguay está
completamente rezagado este y las
grandes transformaciones que requiere
nuestro estado le van a obligar a
establecer estos grandes acuerdos con
todos los sectores políticos vamos a ver
si si va a ser capaz de de de de poder
hacer esto llevar esto adelante